i didn't really have anyone to turn to
for erica asakwe having a named police
officer to help when she reported the
physical assault she suffered would have
made a real difference
you can imagine reporting something so
harrowing and so um traumatic
to the police and then feeling alone
because you've already felt alone
throughout your experience
so to have someone to turn to to speak
to
you would feel supported you feel like
you're being listened to and it can
definitely impact the way that
someone heals from their experience as
well
this is what boris johnson is now
promising victims of crime alongside
league tables to track the response time
of the 101 and 999
services his plan to reinforce trust in
his government
in the wake of kovid 19. good policing
is based on contact
between the public and police officers
and them knowing each other's names and
having a relationship we think is uh
very important for the legitimacy and
the sense of
you know ownership of the public of the
police mission
but police bosses have branded the plan
unworkable and worn an already
overstretched force won't be able to
deliver on the pledge
labour says the government is
undermining officers the very practical
issue about whether somebody should have
a named officer
we just need to test that i mean what
does it mean in terms of officers who
work
shifts maybe doing an evening shift or
not a daytime shift
what does it mean in terms of cover and
sickness absence or annual leave where
the officer won't be available
are we going to find ourselves where
victims are chasing around for a police
officer they struggle to tie down
for those reasons for officers who are
already very much overworked
the prime minister will announce the
full plan on tuesday when he will put
community policing at the heart of his
beating crime promise
but as the policing federation says it
has no confidence in the home secretary
and some bosses warning forces could
slow down response times in protest over
pay
there are big questions over whether
he'll be able to deliver
kate mccann sky news